in the previous lecture we explored how
dimensionality reduction techniques can
help us understand the variance of data
using principal component analysis last
time we use this small data set the data
set has only two types of breast cancer
normal like and cloud and low and of
course using PCA we clearly saw
separation between the two groups but
now we will take a different data set
this data set has all the subtypes of
cancer and now this becomes a much more
challenging problem not only do I have
more samples I also have more subgroups
so we will explore how PCA can give us
some insight but it's not very
conclusive so we will refer to
clustering techniques in order to take a
better look at the different options
that we have to deal with the data and
its complexity I am going to take the
file that I gave you and I'm going to
press Continue and just to explore
what's in at first use PCA now PCA
principal component Alice's should give
me some kind of an understanding of what
trends major trends could be found in
the data so let's take a look after the
pipeline runs so the pipeline finished
let's take a look at the results and of
course download all results zip but in
our case let's first take a look at the
plot and the plot will be showing us the
samples and mark them by the type of
group that they belong to so several
things that we need to take a look at
here let's open this
and the first thing that we see is that
luminol samples are all on this side and
then all the rest are on this side now
what is good about this is that we know
that luminol our luminol subtypes are
separated from the rest and we can even
say that maybe this basal group is also
fairly easy to distinguish but it's not
so easy about the other ones the second
thing that we can see is the percentage
of variance that these PCs explain so
together they actually don't explain
that much you can see that this is about
twelve point sixty to eighteen point
zero eight so together that's about 30%
so really not that much and so also
together with this you then have other
components other principal components
you can see that on this one for example
there is a better maybe separation
between cloud and low and then basil and
normal like right so they are more
separated here on the opposite side
they're all more grouped together so
probably not the best combination of
principal components but because we can
see here pretty good separation now we
can assume that if we use a different
method a method that doesn't just reduce
the damage in the dimensionality but a
method that actually assigns these to a
specific group so how do we do that we
need to use clustering techniques so
let's go back to the platform and let's
create another unsupervised analysis
pipeline will upload the same file that
we have cell lines marked and press
Continue let's do start and let's try
hierarchical clustering now here I know
that I have four clusters so I can just
put in four here for example I do need
to transpose and then here you can see
that I have multiple types that I can
select so let's elect 42 and keep this
at euclidean click on save and then end
okay so this is going to be my H clust
okay let's run this pipeline then let's
create another one again upload the same
file start now let's try k-means and
then you can also read about what
k-means does when you see the pop-up you
can pause there and read how k means is
different
okay and let's create another one again
we'll upload the same file
spec you can see also how many do we
expect let's expect for
run pipeline screen unsurprised okay
let's add file
TBS can
okay so let's take a look at
hierarchical clustering what did we get
here so we have all of the expression
data marked we have PDF file that we can
take a look at again let's take a look
at that one okay and let's try and see
so here we also see two main clusters
but it's hard to see kind of what else
can we find here without annotating them
so let's go ahead and look at the
clusters only table so here's our
cluster only let's open it up in Excel
okay and let's adhere the information
that we have about these clusters and we
are going to take this group and we're
just going to do pay special transpose
and now we have groups maybe this is not
the best clustering right so the way we
can know is we can sort this let's say
ascending okay and let's see which ones
work correctly so we see that two normal
likes were grouped with basil but at
least basil and normal-like are all
number one cloud and lo is done
correctly but luminol also has two and
three the result isn't that great I
created a few more pipelines including
DB scan k-means with other iterations
and cluster number hierarchical
clustering with a different number of
clusters and others now I'm doing this
just to compare the results so let's
take a look at what comes out I
assembled all of the results and I'm
looking at the differences between them
and what comes out is that k-means and
higher are
clustering actually produce the best
results out of all most of the time and
the predicted cluster is correct but it
oftentimes happens that for luminal
there seems to be two different clusters
1 & 2 in this example or in this example
it was 2 & 3 now they don't exactly
match up but this isn't biologically
meaningless in fact we know that a lot
of classifiers identify luminal as
having two subtypes luminal a luminal B
but which technique is the best how do I
choose something that will work better
for my data well the simple answer is of
course I need to know a lot more about
my data before I jump to selecting one
method over the other but I also need to
understand the methods so in our next
lecture let's talk about how these
different methods compare to each other
and what situations would they work best